ils sont près de saint-chefs d'État et
de gouvernement réunis à sharm-el-sheik
en Égypte les premiers ministres de la
Grande-Bretagne de l'Espagne et de
l'Italie sont présents le président de
la France celui des Émirats arabes unis
aussi mais Justin Trudeau bris par son
absence notre délégation à la cop27 va
être menée par Steven gilbaune on va
continuer le lit de Chypre du Canada en
matière de mettre un prix sur la
pollution à travers le monde pourtant
l'heure est grave rappelle le secrétaire
général de l'ONU we are in the fight for
lifeing nous menons la plus importante
bataille de nos vies et nous sommes en
train de la perdre bientôt
climatique sera bientôt irréversible
ajoute-t-il une nouvelle fois il implore
les pays participant à collaborer pour
éviter la catastrophe déjà les délégués
se sont mis d'accord pour discuter d'une
compensation qui serait versée par les
riche au pays les plus pauvres qui
subissent déjà de plein fouet l'impact
des changements climatiques au printemps
prochain pas dans un an deux ans au
printemps prochain nous avons demandé au
FMI à la Banque mondiale à l'OCDE nous
nous proposer des solutions très
concrètes pour activer ces mécanismes
financiers innovants pour nous permettre
de développer des accès à des liquidités
nouvelles des capacités de près
nouvelles pour des pays y compris des
pays à revenus intermédiaires qui sont
touchés par ces chocs donc il va se
morfine on ne veut pas de nouvelles
promesses d'être financière rétor que ce
militant africain ce que nous voulons
c'est que les pays riches soient
redevables de tout ce qu'ils ont déjà
promis
les délégués de cette cop27 ont dix
jours pour prouver qu'ils sont prêts à
passer de la parole aux actes ici lise
Villeneuve Radio-Canada Montréal